[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Have you enjoyed?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We have a little business today
that has to do with the class.
And then I want to take
off my academic hat
and tell you things that I
wish somebody had told me
when I was graduating.
I won't be able to
tell you all of them,
I'm sure, because I could
go on for hours with things
that I wish I had been
told at some point.
But we'll get in
as many as we can.
So let's start with that which
had to do with the class.
I promised you a demonstration
that you would remember,
perhaps, forever and that is
very much related to something
that you studied.
But we'll put a different
light on the effects.
And we'll talk about that.
What we have is a recording--
very poor quality, but that
doesn't make any difference.
It was made about 30 years
ago in my living room.
We had a very--
we had this 1/8
of a sphere, which
was really well equalized,
well-designed by any standard.
And we decided to find out what
a room really did to things.
Like the sound we produced from
a loud speaker or from you.
And we made this
recording, played it
through the loudspeaker, put a
microphone in normal listening
position in the living room,
took what was on the mic--
when was recorded.
And we recorded what
went into the microphone,
put it back into the speaker.
Came through again, recorded,
Came through again,
up to six times.
And I think you'll hear
the first time through.
Now, mind you, that's
sort of like a second time
through because you're
going into a room.
Again, you're not
listening over headphones.
The normal modes in this
room aren't the same--
at the same frequency.
So going through the
same system twice
is much worse than going
through two different ones,
but you'll get the message.
Basically, you'll hear
the so-called original.
And it's music first, speech,
next, speech sample, next.
And a pink noise, which is equal
energy per percentage spectrum
third.
And then you'll hear, second
round with that will be--
after it's gone through twice.
And the third time you
hear it, the three--
they will have gone
through six times.
Now, what I want you
to concentrate on
is how each of these
sounds deteriorates as it
goes through this process.
See if you can't relate
the music deterioration
to the speech deterioration
to the noise deterioration.
And I will put on the board
what would seem like something
obvious to you.
It may not seem so obvious by
the time the demonstration gets
to the end.
I will put on a little matrix
telling which one is playing.
So let's go.
The original.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Renting a car in Athens is no
more complicated than renting
one in Miami Beach.
The only requirements are
an American driver's license
and $50 down.
The rental fee is
less than $3 a day
to which is added a mileage
fee and the cost of gasoline.
I hired a Volkswagen, at
the expense worked out
to a neat $10 per
100 kilometers.
It would have been
less, no doubt,
if I had adopted the
Greek habit of turning off
the engine on downgrades.
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[UNIDENTIFIED NOISE]
[END PLAYBACK]
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Renting a car in Athens is no
more complicated than renting
one in Miami Beach The
only requirements are
an American driver's
license and $50 down.
The rental fee is
less than $3 a day,
to which is added a mileage
fee and the cost of gasoline.
I rented a Volkswagen,
and the expense
worked out to a neat
$10 per 100 kilometers.
It would have been
less, no doubt,
if I had adopted the
Greek habit of turning off
the engine on downgrades.
[END PLAYBACK]
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[UNIDENTIFIED NOISE]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And now the
reason for the chart.
Go ahead.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[UNIDENTIFIED NOISE]
[LAUGHTER]
That is Carmen.
[UNIDENTIFIED NOISE]
[END PLAYBACK]
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[UNIDENTIFIED NOISE]
PROFESSOR: Certain similarity
of Carmen to speech.
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
This one, think about strongly.
It tells the whole story.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[UNIDENTIFIED NOISE]
[END PLAYBACK]
Now, I'm sure you
know what this is.
It's the normal modes.
You go through a
frequency response once,
you go through it twice.
You square it, right?
Cascaded the same function with
itself, you get the square.
And so it goes each time.
And if you have a filter that is
a reasonably narrow band, when
you square that thing,
it being comes something
that goes way up here,
becomes a much higher Q.
You can figure out--
I didn't happen to do
it this turn, but it's
easy to figure out the Q of
these modes of the normal--
these normal modes of the room.
Because you figured out
reverberation time already,
and that means, as you
saw in the derivation,
that you turn on a
sine wave in a room
and it decays exponentially.
Well, that's exactly
what you would
have if you had a two
pole network, which
has a response that
looks like that anyway.
And twice this distance
is the bandwidth.
So twice the decay
rate that it decays at.
The alpha there will
give you the bandwidth
of the normal modes, and
they're pretty high Q.
And you may not have noticed
or paid attention to it
the first time, but it took--
when we got to the sixth time,
it took time for the sound
to build up.
It didn't just start right on
like the original music did.
It built up.
And then, when it finished,
it died out slowly.
Because the Q of these
filters getting larger
each time caused this fellow
bandwidth to get much smaller.
And therefore, it died out
much, much, much more slowly.
If you try that same experiment
with other equipment,
like an amplifier.
You go through 40 times.
And if you adjust it so that
the frequency response is OK--
I mean, if it's a few
dB down or something,
then every time
that gets amplified.
And then you will hear it.
But if you adjust the
frequency response,
you can go through
an amplifier 40 times
and not know it, except
maybe for noise level.
And so it's a way of putting
a magnifying glass on what's
causing the problem.
One could argue here--
and you'll just have to
take our word for it,
that we worried about that
and paid attention to it--
that you're going
through two things.
Yes, all the amplifiers and all.
We actually did go
through all of them
quite a number of times.
But you're also going
through the loudspeaker.
But take my word
for it, that was--
what you heard was not that.
It was, in fact, the
normal modes of the room.
Before changing completely
from the academic side now,
I just would like to say
a few words with respect
to what I regard as excellent
performance of the teaching
assistants.
Yesterday, just to
give you an idea,
there was a meeting
to discuss grades.
Now, they actually prepared
all the numbers every
which way you could
possibly look at them--
columns and columns and columns.
And they-- a meeting
like this could
have lasted 15 minutes, after
all the preparation that
was done.
It lasted five hours.
Because there was enormous
discussion in each case,
what do we know
about the individual?
Do the quizzes really
represent what that person
knows about the subject?
Did that person have--
that particular person
have a really bad time in his
term, in which the average came
down because of that?
And all of that only
happens when somebody cares.
And these teaching assistants
have, just like you,
all the exams coming up.
They have a lot to do, and they
could have recommended that it
be a 15 minute meeting,
but they didn't.
So I have particular thanks
to all of them to [INAUDIBLE]..
Get up.
Come on up.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
[? Monish ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
To the head teaching assistant,
Carlos [? Cabrera. ?]
Where are you?
[APPLAUSE]
And also, by the way, in terms
of hours that they spent,
they spent many more hours
than they were either
compensated for or
assigned to on this task.
I hope that they have.
I know they enjoyed it.
I hope they have
learned something,
and I'm going to
ask each one of them
if they would like to say
a few words in the moment.
But there's another person
I would like to acknowledge,
and that is Neil
[INAUDIBLE],, who
was a teaching assistant in
this subject a few times,
did a magnificent job.
And he-- Neil?
[APPLAUSE]
Neil helped out this term
with the Bose people.
And the WPI.
He taught the same
course here at Bose.
And, as I say, you did a
fantastic job last year
at MIT and the year
before that and here now.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]!
Oh, [INAUDIBLE] isn't here.
That's-- yeah, yeah.
By all means.
Is he here?
Oh!
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE] Sorry about that.
I was looking at the faces
here and he had just gone
to pick up his brother at the--
boy, you must have really--
really traveled.
That's not why I missed you.
I forgot.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I just wondered if
any of you would like
to just say a couple of words.
[INAUDIBLE],, since
you were last?
You better come here maybe.
This is totally
unplanned, so I--
TA: I just wanted to say,
it was a great experience.
PROFESSOR: this
works, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
TA: Does it work?
OK, good.
It was a-- it's an
experience teaching.
I taught last year and I learned
a lot, and taught this year
and I learned even more.
Neil was my TA when I took
it, so I've certainly learned
quite a bit from him as well.
And it's really
quite a pleasure.
And all the time we put into
it is, from my perspective,
worth it.
And I hope you
feel the same way.
Many of you as students would
be good teaching assistants.
And near the end, we'd
like you to sign up
if you have any
interest for next year.
And it's-- lots of students
who I know sort of bypass
the teaching assistant role,
because they want to do
research, Dr. Bose has told us.
Having been a teacher, and
knowing how much I enjoy it
and how much I benefit from
it, I suggest it to all of you,
whether you continue
with your studies or not.
Because there's nothing
that teaches you
material better than teaching.
And I'll tell you, I
was frightfully nervous
the first time I taught.
And each time the semester
starts, I am nervous also.
Because I'm sure most of you
are at a much higher level
than I am.
So you just have to stand up
there and be confident and say
no, even if you're right.
[LAUGHTER]
So thank you.
I really did enjoy it.
[APPLAUSE]
TA: [INAUDIBLE] said
is, I agree with that.
I mean, there's really
nothing like teaching.
You really don't know how
well you know something
until you have to teach
it to somebody else.
And like I said, it's a
scary experience at first.
And like [INAUDIBLE] said,
this is my second time around.
And every single time I think
I've gone through this course,
I've learned just as much.
I've learned actually more,
I think, in teaching in class
than I had as a student
learning in class.
And it's just--
I agree with [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, if you get
a chance, please
do take the time to teach.
It's an incredible
experience, because not only
do you learn from--
I've learned not
only from teaching
by listening to Dr. Bose and
the other teaching assistants,
but I learn a lot from you guys.
I mean, everybody sees
problems in different ways.
Everybody has their own unique
solution to a given problem.
And the more I see of that,
the more amazed-- the more ways
I see a problem.
And it's just incredible.
So I'd just like to thank Dr.
Bose and the teaching staff
and all of you guys for making
such a great experience for me.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
TA: Well, actually, I just want
to agree with [INAUDIBLE] also.
[LAUGHTER]
I'd like to add that I was also
very nervous when I started out
teaching.
I don't think I would have
been able to stand up and talk
to guys unless I had
taught this semester.
It was an excellent
experience just standing up
and sort of learning
from students
and learning from the
other teaching assistants.
And, of course, Dr. Bose.
I was actually taking a number
of classes this semester.
And it was a very
busy schedule for me,
but I think this was the
most enjoyable thing that I
did this semester.
And I don't want to repeat
what [INAUDIBLE] said,
but I'd just like to thank all
of you and the teaching staff
and, of course, Dr. Bose.
Thank you very much once again.
And try teaching if you
can, and even if you're
taking lots of classes.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: How many did
you take in the end?
TA: Five.
PROFESSOR: How many?
PROFESSOR: Whoa!
She was taking five
classes at the same time.
[INAUDIBLE]
TA: I'm going to tell you guys a
couple of really short stories,
sort of anecdotes,
to sort of illustrate
what the other TAs said.
I can't think of a
better way to make
an impact on someone's
career and the path
that they're taking.
Last year, when I took the
class, for a number of reasons,
I was having a
difficult time at MIT.
And that manifested in all
sorts of problems academically--
a lack of confidence, a
lack of concentration.
I was really doubting myself.
And the class, as it
was taught by Dr. Bose,
really grabbed my interest.
But even though I was sitting
in the lectures in awe,
I would go to the problem
sets and I would get stuck.
I really struggled
with the material.
And the person who really
helped me out big time
and pushed me along and
taught me to believe in myself
was Neil [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, he wasn't my TA.
I just went to him.
I said Neil, I need some help.
And he spent many,
many hours with me.
Some of the best advice he gave
me was, put your pencil down,
look at it, and think about
what you want to do first.
And I use that on
every problem now.
And if you want to hear
about how becoming a teaching
assistant can make a difference
in your understanding, when
I took the exams last year,
you guys think you stayed long,
I was always one of
the last ones to leave.
I mean, I stayed
really, really late.
And I think I annoyed Neil a
couple of times in doing so.
But when this semester
rolled around, [INAUDIBLE]
said look, we need you and
[INAUDIBLE] to beta test
the exam.
What?
[INAUDIBLE] I've got
like a full load, man.
I can't spend six hours
like I did last year.
There's no way!
I mean, I can't do it.
He said, [INAUDIBLE],, look,
you've got to take the test.
We need your feedback.
You and [INAUDIBLE]
are the only people
that can really give us an idea
of where there are ambiguities,
what needs to be clarified.
So grudgingly, I took
the test from him.
And I set aside six hours,
because I said to myself,
I'm not going to spend
less than six hours.
I really felt that it was
going to take me that long.
But after having presented
the material in class,
after having sat
with the graduate TAs
and really preparing
the material,
I just noticed that
in lecture I began
to see things which I struggled
with so tremendously last year.
Things became
conceptualized in a way
that I hadn't been able to
think of problems before.
And, I mean, by inspection,
the exam fell apart.
It really did.
And it did not take me--
what the hell, it
took me like an hour
or so to get through the exam
that the years prior had taken
me like a good five or six.
So if you really want to make
a difference in someone's life,
I can't think of a better way.
And if you want to
improve upon yourself,
I can't think of a better way.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TA: Well, I have to say that
I agree with all the TAs.
No, I'm not going to
repeat what they said.
I think the basic idea
has been communicated,
that if you think you
learned something,
you really didn't learn
as much as we did.
I just want to thank all
the teaching assistants.
They have been of great help.
I couldn't have done
it without their help
and their support all the time.
And I want to thank my students
for teaching me so much.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TA: I just want to take a
minute to thank Dr. Bose.
He's the first person
I've ever met who
cares so much about teaching.
And he's the man who
taught me everything
I know about how to
communicate information
and how to teach to people.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So much for the academics.
Now we go on to--
yes?
AUDIENCE: You forgot somebody.
PROFESSOR: Who did I forget?
AUDIENCE: AJ.
AJ was the TA for
the WPI [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
I did not--
I was not connected to that
and I'm very, very sorry.
AUDIENCE: No problem.
PROFESSOR: Would you
like to say anything?
AUDIENCE: Ditto.
PROFESSOR: Ditto, OK.
Good.
What faces you in the future
is something that most of you
don't expect.
And yet, statistically,
it's an absolute fact.
If you look at the
alumni records,
you will be amazed at the
dispersion of professions
that students enter that have,
in fact, many cases nothing
to do directly with what they
spent their four or five, six,
seven years studying.
Even in this country, those
people who go into engineering,
the average time
spent by a US graduate
in engineering, in
the field, assuming
that he enters the field
that he was trained for,
the average time that he
spends there is seven years.
In Japan, by the way, it's 20.
A bit different.
Here, many things happen,
some good, some bad.
In many companies, I think
it's somewhat unfortunate,
but the reward for
a good performance
is to make the person a manager.
And all too often, you
lose a wonderful engineer
and you get a terrible manager.
But there are many
reasons why this happens.
But you should be
prepared for this.
And even if you don't
even begin in the field
that you were trained for,
hopefully your education
will enable you
to get to the top.
That's what education
should be all about.
Because the facts
that we may teach
you will be totally irrelevant
if you don't enter that field
and will be mostly
irrelevant if you do.
Because they will change.
They will evolve.
You will develop new things.
And so the facts have
little importance.
The thought process
is everything.
And as these changes come,
don't feel that you are--
my god, you know, I wasted four
years or five or six years,
whatever it is.
That's not the case.
As I think I mentioned
in class, once
the head of surgery at
Mass General Hospital
was an MIT grad.
Now you'll all have a chuckle
if I tell you which course.
[INAUDIBLE]
It had nothing to do with
his skill with a scalpel.
Basically, he'll tell
you what his education
did for him at MIT is
invaluable in the way he thinks.
So what I think I am
going to do is take you
through some
highlights to get you
to appreciate some things about
your career as they come along.
And if you'll excuse me,
I will do this in a way
that I think is most believable.
I don't want to stand up
here and preach to you
and have you wonder--
wow, and maybe it
is your words or whatnot.
So I will use some
personal examples here.
And I don't think I'm atypical.
These same things
have happened to a lot
of people in different forms.
But it's more
believable if it comes
from somebody about himself.
So I'll spend a
little time on that.
And then we'll get to
some of the other topics I
want to get to, like how
do you go out job shopping?
And how do you get
creativity really rolling?
Well, I'd like to illustrate
some changes that come along,
that will come along with high
probability in your lives,
that you may not like.
And we'll talk about
what you can do about it.
When I finished my masters
here, I went over to Philips
to work for--
in Holland for the summer.
And I had arranged a doctorate
thesis and conformal mapping
with [? Gillerman. ?]
By the way,
this group is different
than just the MIT class.
So some of you will have
heard parts of this,
but I'll try to make that short.
And I came back about
a week or two late,
but I had this
thesis all arranged
and a research
assistantship, and I
knew that food would
be on the table
because the research
assistantship was there.
And I came rolling into
Building 20 and went to my desk
and there was a little
note on the desk.
It said, please see the director
of the laboratory, research
laboratory of electronics.
So I picked it up and I went in.
It was Dr. Jerome
Wiesner, who was later
President Kennedy's
science advisor
and then President of MIT.
But he was head of the
research laboratory, RLE,
that exists today.
And so he and the assistant
director were there.
And I sat down and wondered why
I was asked to come in there,
since they had nothing
to do with my thesis,
except I was working
in that laboratory.
But the thesis was all
theoretical, in any case.
And so they told me the
story about Norbert Wiener.
And I also wondered why they
were telling me that story.
And then it came
down to the fact
that they thought Norbert
Wiener had some things that
were really applicable in
electrical engineering,
and they'd been thinking--
because he had a number of them
over the decades,
but they thought
he had some material more
recently that they really
wanted to get, to transfer
into electrical engineering.
And then they said
that, look, we
have tried three
doctorates on this program.
And they did all right.
But we think that there's
something there still.
And then came the bombshell.
They said, we would like
you to work on this.
And I was shocked.
And I thought maybe they
didn't know, you know,
that I have a research
assistantship.
I have a professor that
I thought the highest of,
and I'm very happy.
And so I explained
that immediately.
And they said, yes, we know.
But we would like
you to work on this.
And I was really
annoyed at this point,
because it was a
totally different field.
I had taken a minor in math.
But, you know, to
work for Norbert
Wiener with a minor
in math is like,
you know, studying calculus
when you don't know arithmetic.
And so I listened and
I finally said, look,
are you drafting me?
And they said yes.
Well, it's the only time I
know of anybody being drafted
to do a doctorate thesis.
And then they could see the
shock on my face at this point.
And they said, well, let's--
look, if you don't like it
after a year, you come back,
and we'll let you go back to
the thesis you wanted to do.
And so I was, what?
23 at the time, and I
was really, really upset.
So I said, look, if you're
not going to give me a choice,
I'm not going to come back
into this office in one year
and start over.
If this is my only
choice, here I go.
So I went out.
And they told me
that I had to have
a nominal supervisor in
electrical engineering,
because I was in EE.
And so that this would
be Professor YW Lee.
So I went to see him
and I said, look,
I will see you in a year or two.
I've got to go in the math
department and study math,
since I've been
assigned this project.
He said, no, no, no, no, no.
So he gave me a
whole pile of-- it
must have been about 50 pages or
so of typed, mainly equations.
And said, you just read this.
[LAUGHTER]
So I read it.
I read it twice a day
for about six months,
and it didn't make
any sense at all.
So I started to go over to the
math department in the library
and read anything that
I thought was related.
I wasn't even sure what was
related to this mathematics.
So I started reading
everything I could.
And I kept coming back to Lee
and telling him, oh, boy, this
is--
I don't even know
anything about this.
And this is ridiculous.
And he didn't know
anything either.
And so he just kept saying,
don't worry, it'll come.
And I did worry, and
it wasn't coming.
And so, this went on
until about February.
It started in September and
went on until about February.
And then Lee came into my
office one day and said,
oh, by the way, he
said, there's going
to be an international
conference of mathematicians
here at MIT this summer in June.
And you are to speak
on Wiener theory.
[LAUGHTER]
Aie, aie, aie.
At this point, I really,
literally, came to the point
where you have these
dreams where you have--
somehow you've wound up
in class in grade school
and you forgot to get dressed.
And how do you get out?
And, you know, it was
just a horror experience.
And I never went to see
Wiener during all this period.
Because what could I say,
that I don't understand,
were about the only words I
could utter to Norbert Wiener.
That's all I knew.
And so I begged to get out of
this thing, this presentation,
because these were-- the top
mathematicians from the world
were gathered in
this, as I was told.
And I begged him
to get out of this.
And no, no, don't worry,
don't worry, it'll come.
So I kept reading this thing
twice a day, twice a day.
I read it day and
night and tried
to get my mind off of the fact
that I couldn't understand it.
Because if you focus
on something like that,
you're dead.
If you think you cannot do
something, you will not do it.
So you've got to get your mind.
You have-- And you're going to
bump into problems like that.
Get that kind of thinking
out of your head.
Because that is an absolute
block to any kind of progress.
So I kept going, kept going.
And I gave up on visiting Lee
after about four or five times.
I said, look, he's just
going to tell me, keep at it,
it'll come.
So finally, just two weeks
before, one afternoon I
read it--
and oh, by the way.
I found some mistakes.
As I was beginning to get
a little understanding,
I could understand enough in
these huge integral equations
that there were some errors.
At least I thought there were.
So I went to him,
I said, you know,
this seems like there's
some errors here.
He said, oh I didn't--
I forgot to tell you.
He said, this was typed
from the back of envelopes
that Norbert Wiener
had scratched on
in Paris by a secretary
that didn't type English,
let alone math.
And so he said, you
can expect some errors.
[LAUGHTER]
I can tell you.
At least I thought,
well, you know,
maybe I'm getting to the level
where I can see the errors.
Well, just two weeks before
the conference was to start,
I read it one afternoon.
And bang, everything
became crystal clear.
Just absolutely clear.
And I really sat back that
night and I said, my god,
is Lee a professor or a prophet?
I mean, he had this seemingly
incredible confidence.
And the conference began,
and I got up there.
It was the first time
I had talked publicly.
And, oh my god, I mean,
my throat got dry.
I was so nervous in the
first couple of minutes I--
and this audience out there.
And Wiener was in the audience.
And I-- boy, I didn't think
I was going to survive.
But after about two or
three minutes of that,
everything came back
and you started going.
It was fine until somebody
raised their hand.
And what happens when you're
in the front of a group
and somebody raises their
hand, the first thing you see
is the hand.
And then you follow it down.
And guess who it
was connected to?
Norbert Wiener.
And I thought, at that
point, it was all over.
I mean, if there had been a
panic button in the podium,
I would have gone
straight through it.
And so he asked the question.
And I was so nervous I couldn't
even listen to the question.
I thought I had it.
I answered it incorrectly.
And very calmly, very politely,
he said exactly the same thing.
He didn't say, you didn't
answer it or anything else.
He just went through
the same question again.
And somehow, that got to
me, and I calmed down,
and I was able to answer
it, with great fortune.
And then the whole thing turned.
I mean, I went on through
the presentation, just
no problems at all, like
I'd been teaching for years.
And then at the end of
the whole conference,
they had all the
mathematicians fill out
a form relative to the
value of the whole two week
conference, et cetera.
And one day, Lee
walked into my office
and he said, maybe you'd like to
know that your presentation was
voted to be the best.
And I thought, my god.
You know, if they only
knew what was inside
of me when I was making it.
And also, you know, I'm
not a mathematician.
And it turns out that you can
do things in other fields.
You really can.
That made a huge
difference in my life.
Because when I realized for
the first time that, gee,
you could come to a
level in another field
that you didn't know
anything about a year ago--
with intense effort, to be
sure, and a lot of time spent--
but it gives you--
whenever that happens,
it gives you a confidence that
you are now on another plateau,
and you're ready to go up again.
And it takes away a lot of the
fear that you would have had.
I went through more
fear in that year
than you could ever imagine.
And that started a
10-year relationship
between Norbert Wiener and I in
which we met almost every day,
and it was something that
everything I've ever earned
could never even
begin to pay for.
Well, when I graduated, or when
I was doing the final thesis
exam, Wiesner, Jerry Wiesner,
was one of the examiners.
And after the exam--
it was over in the math
department, I think it was.
And we had a long way to
walk back to Building 26.
And he asked me,
what am I doing?
Well, it turned out that
in February of the year--
I was going to graduate in June.
And February, Norbert
Wiener had said to me--
at that time, by the
way, my frame of mind
was, I couldn't wait to
get out of the industry
and get a research job.
I had studiously avoided
all forms of teaching.
I knew that was the one thing
that I never wanted to do.
And so I was certain of that.
And all teaching assistantships
weren't of any interest.
I always wanted to research,
and I lived on that.
And then-- and I couldn't wait
to get out there to do it.
And in February or
January of that year
that I was going to graduate,
Norbert Wiener one day
said, you know, Bose, your
heritage is from India.
You should spend a year there.
Apply for a Fulbright.
Well, if anybody else in the
world had said that to me,
I would have fought
them tooth and nail.
But I had come to respect
him so highly by that time
I found myself
saying, all right.
Without even thinking.
I mean, if my parents had
told me that or anybody else
had told me that, oh god.
You know?
Because I was afraid of
spending any time away
from this that your
level would go down,
without exercising
the math and whatnot.
And so I found myself just
like that saying, all right.
And I did it.
But then, a couple months
later, I got a little worried.
I said, you know, suppose I--
I'm applying for this thing
now, and suppose I don't get it.
Oh, boy, the end of
the line comes in June.
I don't have a job
and I have no income.
So I went to Lee--
Professor Lee-- and I told
him, there's a problem.
I think I'd better start
going out interviewing just
to back this thing up.
With the same confidence, he
says, don't worry, it'll come.
He said, don't do that.
He said, Norbert Wiener is
writing the recommendation.
So I took him for his
word, and then it happened.
It all came.
But at the graduation in
June, coming out of the exam,
Jerry Wiesner said to me--
he asked me what I was doing.
And I told him the whole story.
I was going to India
for a year, and that I
was going to use the
summer to make certain
that I found the job I want in
industry so that the minute I
come back I'm all set.
And he said, well,
what about teaching?
And I explained to him
why I didn't want anything
to do with that.
And so we walked a few more
paces down the corridor,
and he said, in
those days, you used
to have to be an instructor--
a teaching assistant,
and then an instructor,
and then faculty.
And so he said,
well, look, suppose
we would bypass these things
and put you on the faculty.
And I said, well, you
know, thank you very much,
but I don't want anything
to do with teaching.
And I know what I want.
I want research.
And that ended the conversation.
And then we walked
a little further.
And I thought, you know, they
were so kind to offer all this.
Maybe I could ask for
something I really wanted.
I said, could I
stay in the summer?
I have a little money saved
from the research assistantship.
I can live.
And could I stay with no salary.
I just bought a loudspeaker, and
the thing measured very well,
and it sounded horrible.
And I want to find out why.
And if I could stay here
and use your equipment,
I don't want a
salary, but I do--
would like to use the anechoic
chamber and equipment.
And he said, absolutely.
No problem.
So that was the end of the
conversation, and I did that.
And that started to
change my career sort of.
But another change I never
expected to be in this area.
But then I-- a
week or so before--
the two weeks before the plane
was to leave in September,
I was in the pool
at MIT, and I was
coming to the end of the lane.
And somebody-- I
don't remember who.
I think it may have
been Thomas [INAUDIBLE],,
who is of digital fame today.
But he reaches arm over
the edge of the pool
and said, congratulations.
And we went through a big thing.
It seemed to be interminable.
It must have lasted
a minute or so.
For what?
No you know what!
No, I don't.
Finally, he was convinced
I didn't know what.
And so he said, well, he
said, the full catalog is out.
And you're on the
faculty, with a leave
of absence for the first year.
Then I thought,
you know, come on.
This is-- now I thought
he was pulling my leg.
And another minute
or so, he sort of
convinced me it was true.
So when I was in the
shower room and changing,
I decided what to do
about this strange thing.
And I decided, before
I left the pool, that I
would do it for two years.
And I was dreadfully
afraid of absence.
Then I would be three years.
I would go away one
year and two years.
I thought, oh my god, I'll be
done, as far as research goes.
Because in the faculty,
there's so many duties
that I don't have the time
that I wanted to have.
And so I went to Lee.
I never even-- I didn't
even know who to go to.
And I went to Lee
and I said, you know,
I've been told that this
thing is in the catalog.
And you know, I think
I'll do it for two years.
Well, as far as I
know, to this day
there's never been any agreement
between MIT and myself.
I did it.
I didn't even know
how much I was
going to get until I came back.
And at the end of
the first month
I think there was a paycheck.
So I decided to do it
only for two years.
Then what happened
was something that I
didn't realize until a couple
of years ago, what changed that.
And it was in the second term.
I was teaching a course
in statistical theory
of communication, grad course.
And it was a big grad course.
And there was another
professor teaching it
who had been a teacher of mine.
And being a junior, I had to
do all the sorting of the cards
that came in and whatnot.
And they were-- out
of about 50 students,
there were three or
four of them who said,
on their card, no offense, but I
would like Professor So and So.
He was a very good teacher.
And, well, you know, when
you read that, one feeling,
sort of, it hurts you.
But the next minute, you
realize, look, you know,
he's very well known.
He is a good teacher, and
the student was very polite
about saying, no offense,
but I would like that person.
Well, what went
through my mind then--
and I never realized
that this is
what changed my decision until
just a couple of years ago.
For some reason, I had
to give a talk between--
it was even more recent.
Had to give a talk at the
centenary of his birth.
What happened was
I said to myself--
and I remember that now,
that, you know, one day, I'm
going to try to become such
a good teacher that students
might say, no offense
to somebody else,
they would like to have me.
And saying that
was a commitment.
Because you weren't
going to achieve that
in one more year by any means.
So that's what happened.
And so I went into the--
marched into the classroom.
And I was a professor
by definition.
I didn't know anything
about it and had
to try to learn what
it meant to teach.
But I found it interesting.
And found it interesting
to the extent that--
this was 1957 when I got back--
to the extent that
when patents had
issued in electronics
and acoustics,
and it came time that MIT
had to decide what they
were going to do with these.
If they take them at that
time-- and may be the same now--
you get 12% of the
royalties that they get.
And if they decide not
to take the patents,
they give them to the faculty.
Well, they gave them to me.
And I-- these were
patents in electronics,
and switching amplifiers and
other patents and acoustics.
So I thought, ah.
Now, by this time,
I really realized
I wanted to stay at MIT.
So let's license these patents.
So my former roommate at
MIT had gone on to Harvard
and become a patent attorney.
And so he started to
try to license these
with absolutely no luck at all.
Because the acoustic
patents were
useful for the home and
the electronics patents
at that time were only
useful for government,
because they were high
efficiency power processing
and amplification
kinds of devices
that were very expensive--
lightweight, very, very small.
I mean, you could--
we demonstrated the 21 amplifier
that was only that big.
You've seen better
than that now.
And so he was getting
absolutely nowhere.
And one day, Lee--
Professor Lee, the head of
electrical engineering--
he was a very, very
cultured Chinese gentleman.
And he brought me into his
office and he sat me down.
And he said, I would
like-- out of the blue,
he said, I would like to
tell you about my time
during the war, World
War II, in China.
I have no idea why
he wanted to do this.
We normally talked
about technical things.
So he started.
And he said, I could see
that there was a war coming
within '39, or something.
The Japanese were coming in.
And he said, I felt--
he was a professor.
He had graduated under
Norbert Wiener, gone back
to teach in what was Peking.
And he decided he better
get out of the country.
So he came-- and he was a
very conservative person.
He came three days to
Shanghai before the ship came.
And he told me about this.
And the next day, after
he arrived in his hotel,
the Japanese arrived.
And so he never got
out of that hotel
for the duration of the war.
Out of it meaning to
continue his journey.
And he had to survive,
because the money
that he had wasn't adequate
to keep him in the hotel.
So he became-- from a professor
of electrical engineering,
he became a curio dealer.
And he decided to tell me
all about the curio business.
And I'm still wondering, why
is he telling me all this?
But I knew him from the past.
He always had a vision that
was a little bit further.
And so he described that
they go up to the hills,
and they go to the farmers.
And the farmers
dig up many things
just in plowing that are
curios that are of value.
And they take them to
town and they market them.
That's what he did.
And it's a tough business.
He was reduced to a
string bean, literally.
I saw pictures of him.
It was like a walking
skeleton at the time.
But in any case, he
carried on his business.
And then he told
me, you know what
the dream of a curio dealer is?
He said, it has two parts.
First part is that one day
they will go up to the hills
and an article of great value
will come into their hands.
Somebody digs up something
that really has value.
Second part of the dream is that
they will recognize the value
and not just pass it
through as another curio.
And then he said, that's
all I wanted to tell you.
He didn't turn me out, but that
was the end of the discussion.
And I went home and
thought about it,
and it was pretty clear what
he was really saying to me.
Without ever mentioning it.
It was, look, you're trying
to license something.
You have the curio in your hand.
It's very valuable, and
you're trying to license it.
Be careful.
So I came back in the
next day, and I told him.
I said, I thought about what
you told me, and I understand.
And then he and I
and then Sherwin
joined, who was my
student at the time.
And we had-- and then
my former roommate,
who had gone to Harvard.
And we had a number of
sessions about once a month,
the blind leading the
blind, absolutely,
about forming a company.
None of us had to--
maybe one had read a P&L
once, but I certainly hadn't.
And what should we do?
Which of these patents
should we go after?
And all this and that.
And it was literally--
I mean, it would
make a comedy strip
if it had ever
been tape recorded.
But that is finally
what led to the company.
Now, what happens in
life is that you're
dealt many cards which
you don't expect.
You get changed in your career
from one thing to another.
There are some people
who, doesn't matter.
Whichever way they're pointed,
they go after it with gusto
and they rise to the top.
And there are some
people who spend
a good deal of their life
moaning and complaining
that they were
dealt a poor hand.
I'm convinced, not only
from my own experiences
but from watching many,
many people over the years,
that there is no bad hand.
That you can optimize almost
anything you set your mind to.
And you all have a
phenomenal training.
With that training, your
probability of success
is very high.
And the jobs that
you get will be--
not what is given to you,
but what you make of it.
I'll give you an example--
I should say two examples.
For a number of years, I
supervised the Core 6A students
in two companies, General
Electric and Philco.
And it was the
Valley Forge Space
Cetner in General Electric.
And they went through a very bad
period in the '60s where they
had--
a Skybolt contract was canceled.
And they have a contract
with MIT, the 6A companies.
They have to pay MIT so much
once they sign this thing,
and they have to take a
certain number of students.
Well, they were in a very
embarrassing position,
because they had to take
these students that they
had no work for.
So they did.
And it was my turn to go
down and visit the students.
And I went down and the
first student came in.
They were good students.
There were two of them.
First student came
into the office
and he said, oh, this
is hell, he said.
This is ridiculous.
He said, I want out of this.
He said, you know what?
He said, they lost the
contract, this Skybolt contract.
They don't have any work to do.
My boss has been
fired, laid off.
And he said, you know
what they have me doing?
He said, they have me sitting
at the end of an assembly line
and plugging these
transistors into a socket
as they come down.
And I see that the light is
green, I put them in one bag.
And if it's red, I put
them in the other bag.
And he said, this
is stupid stuff,
and he said, I want
out of this program.
And I got both
barrels, I'll tell you.
And so-- but what could we do?
There was no work.
The boss really had been fired.
So, you know, I said, look,
I'll do the best I can.
But I have all your inputs now,
and we'll see what we can do.
And then I had a few
minutes before the next--
the other boy came in.
And I looked over his file.
And, oh, boy, he was
even a better student.
So I thought, oh
god, here we go.
I'm really going to
get it this time.
And so he came in and
I didn't say anything.
I just, well, how's it going?
And he said, well, he said, you
know, they lost the contract,
and my boss has been fired.
And they're laying off people
left and right around here.
And he said, you know, but this
is the most worthwhile term
I've ever had [INAUDIBLE].
He said, this has been
phenomenal for me.
[INAUDIBLE],, boy,
what is going on?
And he said, well, you know
what they had me doing?
No.
I am sitting at the
end of an assembly line
and putting these
transistors in there.
And he said, if the light's
green, I put them in one bag,
and if the light's red, I
put them in another bag.
So by this time, I wondered
if I was really sitting there.
And then he said, but
you know, what I did is,
I went to the management
and I asked him
if the ones that go in the
red bag, namely the bad ones,
I could take home.
And they said, sure.
They're going to throw them out.
And he said, I
bought a microscope.
And I bought some tools to
section these transistors.
And I watched and tried to learn
what was causing the defect.
And he said, in
this term, I have
learned so much that I would
not have learned at MIT,
that I would not have learned
under other conditions
at the job.
He said it has been the
best experience in work
that I have had.
And I then thought, oh
my god, look at this.
Same exact job.
1A enjoyed it-- not the actual
plugging of the transistor,
but the whole experience.
And he learned an
enormous amount from it.
And the other one
looked at it as
if I'd been dealt a bad hand.
Somebody else gave
me the business,
and what a hell of
a position this is.
And that was my most
vivid lesson of,
the job is what you make it.
And you can take--
I can't think of too
many things that you
might be dealt in your life
in terms of jobs that are--
that are, in some
sense, worse than what
this person did was given.
But look at the difference.
And I somehow wish today
I could follow those two
and find out what their relative
progress in life has been.
And I think you can bet which
one has really, really risen.
So I've always found,
in this company as well,
that the people who just don't
have the excitement or interest
and complain about what
they're doing, you can--
they think they want
to do something else,
you put them in that direction.
And sometimes it works,
but usually it doesn't.
And the really best
people are ones
who, you could come up to
them today and say, look,
we really need you who are
going in this direction
to go in that direction.
And by God, they will
go in that direction,
and they will come to the top.
I've seen it where technology
is involved, where just business
is involved.
They grab the vocabulary of the
field, apply their thinking,
and they go at enormous rate
and with enormous quality.
And so it's my feeling
that a good person,
you can spin him around, in
any direction which he ends,
he will just pursue
with excellence.
And we all have the
ability to do that.
And that's-- before I talk a
little bit about how you can
unlock-- how I believe you
can unlock some of that--
I'd like to just give
you some examples.
Some of you have heard the
talk that I gave in the stand
and deliver introduction and
will hear some duplication.
But there were
really, in summary,
three major
experiences in my life
that convinced me of something
that if I could convince you
of in the next 10 minutes,
I would be so happy.
Because I know it's true.
Namely that every one of you
has ability in proportions
that are enormous compared
to what you believe
and what you've ever used.
And the first experience that
really drove that home to me
was Norbert Wiener.
Because he, in those 10
years of association,
we did projects together that
covered all sorts of things,
including the Boston Arm,
which works from your brain.
And it wound us up
in operating theaters
in Mass General Hospital.
A lot of which, by
the way, has never
been published because
we were scared stiff.
The people that-- what we
did is the surgeons and--
I was the head of his group at
Harvard MIT and Mass General.
And the surgeons
were from Harvard.
If people needed a operation
that would involve their arm.
Like if they had a neuroma or if
they needed an older transplant
through calcification,
we would tell them, look,
we will give you
the operation free
if you will allow us to
make some experiments which
won't hurt you.
We wanted to study
what was actually
happening in the nerves
and what you could measure.
And we'd ask these people
who had no arm, for example,
to move their first finger
and their little finger
and their thumb, and make
believe they had an arm.
Or if it was an organ
transplant, they actually did.
And we wanted to study
the nerve transmissions
so that we could make this
arm as realistic as possible
working from the brain.
And we didn't publish
it, because everybody
was scared stiff that some
ambulance chasing lawyer would
go to one of these
papers later and suggest
that he had a headache, and that
the headache was due to this,
and you could get
millions of dollars,
as you can see from the
advertisements of many lawyers
on television.
In any case, in this
process, before we ever
got near the operating theaters.
We had many discussions.
I think it was every
week in Mass General.
And after a couple of months
of this, on one break,
Norbert Wiener was
out of the room.
And the surgeons, who are
the top of orthopedics
at Mass General, rushed
over to me and said, look.
They said, you know, we have
heard that Norman Wiener has
no medical training.
But you can see in these
last couple of months,
every single time we
make the simplest error,
or a complicated
error in anatomy,
he interrupts and corrects us.
And he is always right.
Now tell us what
actually-- where did he go?
And he never had a
day's training in this.
But he knew every
bit of anatomy like--
the medical journals,
never mind like a person.
And he had the ability to--
anything that passed before
his eyes or his ears went in.
Karl Wildes-- professor Wildes
in electrical engineering--
in 1936 took him to a Gilbert
and Sullivan production.
And everybody knew Wiener's
reputation from the time
he was 25 on.
And so Wildes came out
and said, how much of that
do you remember?
Wiener looked down,
what do you want?
And he named a piece.
And you know,
Gilbert and Sullivan,
it goes so rapidly you
can barely understand it.
And right through,
word for word.
Just once in.
That's all you needed.
Well Wiener really--
I don't know if he
made it a point.
He must have.
He worked on me
for 10 years to get
me to understand and
believe that everything he
was was a result of his
father's upbringing.
Which he resented all
his life, by the way.
But he said, without that, I--
all the things that people
think that I am a genius for
would never have developed.
His father was a professor
of languages at Harvard.
And two professors at
the turn of the century
decided to bring up geniuses.
If I shortcut the story,
that's what they decided to do.
And Wiener, at the
age of five or six,
was already reciting
the Iliad and Odyssey
from memory in Greek.
He knew nine languages.
He-- by the way, he learned to
read, write, and speak Chinese
in the six months that
he spent in China.
Somewhere in the
'36, '37 time frame.
And Professor Wildes went
over there the next year
and had the same teacher.
And Wildes told me.
He said, every time
he'd go for a lesson,
the teacher would say,
now Norbert Wiener,
he was a good student.
[LAUGHTER]
So all of this ability
came when the father--
the way the father
brought him up.
Which was, as Wiener felt,
a terrible, terrible thing.
He used to have to
stand beside his father
every night while the father
was correcting work for Harvard.
And the father just
ignored him, until he
made the simplest
error in anything
and verbally
reduced him to dust.
It was a terrible,
terrible experience.
And then, at six years old,
he was told by the doctor
that his eyes were finished.
And that they would be totally
finished if he did not stay
away from reading for a year.
Now the two professors
were competing,
and they were doing
pretty well according
to their measure by this time.
So they decided-- the
father decided, look,
that's no excuse.
That's a problem
you have, but we're
continuing with the experiment.
And he forced him to do
everything in his head.
And Wiener told me that,
when he was seven years old,
he, as a seven-year-old,
recognized that the whole world
had just changed in his vision.
That he could do
things that he couldn't
dream of at the age of six.
And he could recognize
that at seven years old.
He could do this math--
he had to do everything
in his head, his
math in his head.
And he went on and he got his
bachelor's degree from Tufts
at 14, the first of
two doctorates at 18.
And the other fellow did
exactly parallel to Wiener.
It was a very
interesting thing, fact.
The only thing was that
the other one, at 22,
said, to hell with it all,
and became an accountant.
He just decided that he wanted
a different track in life.
But Wiener kept on.
But he had an
insecurity as a result
of that that was enormous.
I mean, he'd go to
these conferences
and he'd come to me afterwards.
He'd say, how did I do?
How did I do?
My god, you know, I understood
only a certain percentage
of what he was talking about.
But he had to be told he was OK.
He never really-- he never
really had the confidence,
but he had the power
that was so enormous.
And what he convinced me--
and I have to believe he made
a real effort over those years.
Because he said it in so
many ways so many times,
that everybody has this ability.
We all come with it.
We just don't believe it,
and we don't develop it.
Nobody develops it for us.
We're already getting near?
How much more?
AUDIENCE: Your decision.
But a quarter after.
PROFESSOR: Oh boy, oh god.
I spent too much time on this.
OK.
So what I-- that
experience was one.
Then I won't go into the
other ones in any detail
now, because I didn't realize
how much time has been--
the other one was, as a result
of that experience with Wiener,
when I was asked to teach
our major course right after
that in electrical engineering,
the first introductory course
in network theory, my
idea was to see what you
could do if you got not
at the cradle but at 19
or 18 years old.
What could you do?
And I spent seven years
to experiment with that.
And then it grew to
be a subject that
was taken by-- a lot
of different courses.
It grew to a third
of the institute,
when EE was only at 25%.
And the students worked--
oh, did they work.
But they worked voluntarily.
I used to have a meeting
with all the section
representatives.
In fact, your father was one
of the section representatives.
And I would tell
the students, now
look, you tell your
section representative when
you've got enough.
This is an exciting subject.
I want to give
you more homework.
And I'm going to
raise it until you
tell the section representative
that's enough, and I'll stop.
Well, he got up to 15
hours a week homework
in a 12 hour subject.
And I hope this isn't
being video recorded.
And I lost my nerve
at that point.
How can you possibly
give 15 hours
homework in a 12 hours subject?
So I stopped at
that level, at 15.
Well, they worked.
And I can tell you the end
result. That the faculty--
this was a different way
of teaching the subject.
But the faculty.
This is where tutorials
all started off, too.
I used to give a
quiz to the faculty.
And I had 30--
I had my total pick of
the faculty at that time.
And I picked the most senior
ones, whose reputation
wasn't on the line.
And the rules for
the tutorial were,
no faculty preparation,
students can
ask whatever they want in
the general subject area,
and I hope the
faculty gets stuck.
And I would announce
that to both of them.
Because I wanted them to see--
Wiener had put
into me that, look,
if you ask anybody
of his generation
in mathematics where
you graduated from,
you will only show
your ignorance.
That's not important.
You ask them who did
they graduate under.
And I really thought about that.
You know, he graduated--
his second doctorate
was under Hardy in Cambridge.
And boy, you look at
the mathematicians that
graduated under
Hardy and there's
something-- there's
something about their pattern
of operation and thinking and
everything that is common.
And what it is is
they got to work
with a very
experienced person who
didn't know the answer to the
problem on their doctorate.
And they go down
the blind alleys,
back up, come over
to another approach.
Why didn't they go this way
instead of 1,000 other ways?
Something of that
process, which none of us
know how, at this day and
age, to teach, rubs off.
And so I wanted to have
the faculty and students
have a chance, in groups of 4
to 1 with the senior faculty,
to experience
that, what happens.
And just to tell
you one result--
it happened actually
twice, but--
it was Professor
Wildes again who
was one of the very senior
teachers at the time.
He was leading one
of the tutorials.
And he walked in, and somebody
asked a question that really
stumped him right off the bat.
He turned the board, and
he was working on it.
About 10 minutes had
gone by, he got nowhere.
And one boy, who
had not spoken--
this was four weeks
into the term--
sort of timidity raised his
hand and said, sir, couldn't you
do the following thing.
Wildes turned
around to the board,
did it, zipped
right to the answer.
And then he was--
his reputation
wasn't on the line.
He was a senior person.
And he turned around
and told the truth.
He said, no-- he was
up there 10 minutes.
And he said, I was trying to
solve the problem but he said,
what was in the
back of my head was,
God, suppose I'm up here
at the end of the hour.
Oh my god, I'm going
to look like a fool.
And he said, I was trying
to get those thoughts out
and trying to devote
myself to the problem.
But he said, one thing I'm
certain of, if I had come up
with a solution, I
would not have realized
such a direct approach.
He said that just wasn't
in my thinking pattern.
He said, this about the
most direct way you can go.
Well, it turns out,
he didn't know,
nor did I know, that that boy
who timidly raised his hand,
he hadn't spoken in
the first four weeks.
He was the one out of the
four that hadn't spoken.
He was on academic
probation, to be thrown out
at the end of the term.
Well, it turns out that in
six weeks was the first quiz.
Then there was the second one
and the third one and a final.
He got 100 in the second quiz--
first quiz, second quiz,
third quiz and the final exam.
He was top of 300
students at MIT.
He soared off of this probation.
All his subjects picked up,
and he just sailed through MIT.
Now, nobody educated that
person in those few moments.
They only unlocked the key
that made the fellow believe
that, gee, I'm no dummy.
I not only solved the problem
the professor admitted
he couldn't solve,
but he told me
that I solved it in
a more direct method
than he would have
even solved it.
He believed, all of
a sudden, in himself.
And that was the key
that took off for him.
And I've seen that happen so
many times in different ways
with people in MIT,
outside of MIT.
Some key turns the person
around and they go after that.
So what I really dearly
want you to understand
is that you all have that.
And if you can believe it--
I mean, I wish I
had more time to--
the last, by the way, was the
[INAUDIBLE],, but most of you
have heard me give
the introduction.
Which he takes people
who were selling drugs,
who couldn't give a
dime, and their parents
give a dime for arithmetic.
And turns them into scholars
that go on through calculus,
chemistry, physics, everything.
And just if I could get you
to believe that that's there.
And when things get
rough-- and they will.
And life is somewhat of a yo yo.
It presents problems that
really depress you at times,
and you get pretty high
on things at other times.
By the way, since
I'm having to cut
a lot of this short now, one
thing I would ask you is that,
concentrate on getting
your satisfaction in life
from what you think
about what you've done,
not from what others think.
What others think is fickle.
It goes up and
down all the time.
You see this.
Actors have great
depression when
they fall out of popularity.
Sports people go
through the same thing.
Because they're looking for
their satisfaction from others.
Those of you that learn
to get it from yourself--
you know everybody has
some measure inside of them
when they're doing well
and when they're not.
And if you get that
satisfaction from when
you are doing something
well, that is lasting.
And it is the only form
that will really help you.
And it's really exciting.
There's nothing like having done
something and worked and worked
and worked on it--
let's say it's
research, which excites me--
and you get a result, finally.
And it's like going through
many, many, many blind alleys
and you finally get something.
That satisfaction is enormous.
And there's another degree of it
which shouldn't be what it is.
If what you were trying
to do was impossible--
was thought to be
impossible by others--
you get more satisfaction.
That's pure ego.
It shouldn't be, but it is.
It's there.
So if you're doing
something that you're
working on that is thought
to be impossible-- in fact,
[INAUDIBLE] in his
classroom has this big sign
that he'd painted.
And it says, if you think
something is impossible,
do not disturb the
person who is doing it.
Good thinking.
Now I'm really going
to cut short here.
The other thing I would like
to just tell you very quickly
about looking at a job.
You heard a lot of it
from our people today.
Look for the people that you're
going to be working with.
Very important.
Because what you will
be will be a reflection
directly of the people that
you come in contact with.
If they are high level,
you will do better.
Same when you pick a school.
When you pick a school,
really the way to do it
is pick the school
with the highest
level of students in it.
Because that causes you to
rise to meet that level.
And that is extremely important.
The other thing is
look at the character
as well as the
ability of the people.
When you go interviewing,
you ask a lot of questions.
This whole business
of going for a job
is like having the
permission to have one date.
And then after the
date, you've got
to decide if you're
going to get married.
And what happens
on the one date?
You're both on
your best behavior.
And so the company that
you're interviewing
is on their best
behavior, because they
are looking for somebody.
And you're on your
best behavior,
because you want to
show them that you're
the person they're looking for.
And you learn very little.
Do a few things.
That won't be expected by the
companies you're interviewing
but, for example, you
spend a lot of time
with the person who
takes you around.
Ask them what their
history is in the company.
When they joined it and
what happened to them,
how they view it.
Then get down to asking,
what are the three things you
like the most?
And what are the three
things you like the least?
Pay attention to the first one,
on what you like the least.
That's usually the thing
that's central in their head.
And when you get interviewed
by people, ask them that.
That's all right.
No problem with
asking questions.
And they're not
prepared for that.
But you will see that,
like in any company,
there are advantages
and disadvantages.
And you want to have a balance.
You want to understand that.
So don't worry about asking
those kind of questions.
What do you like-- what are
the three things you like
the most about the company?
What are three things you like
the least about the company?
You get a very good idea.
And look for-- pardon me.
Look for the
character as well as
the technical
ability of the people
you're going to work with.
Very, very important.
Unfortunately, there's a heck
of a lot of, in this world,
very poor ethics that extend
through corporations also.
Many corporations-- I wonder
if it's not most corporations.
If you are caught
up in something
like that, your
ethics, your principles
will change in the
wrong direction.
Directions that you wouldn't
like them to change.
But it will happen.
So watch those elements
as much as you can.
And then the last thing
I would say very quickly
about companies is,
you will encounter,
in every organization,
not just companies--
whether you join a church or
whether you join an industry,
you will encounter
politics of people.
And that perhaps-- well,
I can't say a priori.
I mean, you're either going
to be part of the solution.
You're going to be indifferent
to it, which is pretty hard,
or you're going to be
part of the problem.
I hope it's not that.
It happens usually
with weak people.
Who, for protection, for
security, build an empire.
And they build this with--
if you want to say, intrigue.
I don't know what
you want to call it,
but they build a
protection around them.
They usually bring weak
people in around them also.
Because they will be shown
up by a strong person.
These kinds of things are the
essence of what can destroy
not only the work
but the people.
Whether we think of--
you probably haven't
thought about this,
but most of the waking hours
that you will have in life
will be in some way
associated with work.
Being there, going to it, coming
from it, thinking about it.
You can't help it.
And it's true for
almost everybody.
In the professional
field, it's very true.
You can't turn the switch off at
five o'clock or whatever it is.
And if that's a
pleasant experience,
your life will be very pleasant.
If it's a bad experience, you'll
be going through life in a way
that you really shouldn't.
Maybe you've heard the
story of the beggar who
sat on the corner, and there
was a well-dressed businessmen
who he noticed was
rushing by every morning
at a certain time.
And one morning, the businessman
was going a little slower.
And so the beggar got
up and thought maybe
he could interrupt him.
And he said, sir, he says, I
see you going here every day.
What are you doing?
And the fellow says,
I'm going to work.
And the beggar says, why?
And he says, so
I can earn money.
The beggar says, why?
Well, so I can save for
this and I can retire.
And he said, well, why
do you want to retire?
He said, so I can
do what I want.
The beggar said, Jesus,
that's what I'm doing now.
So don't go through
life trying to focus
on what you're going to get
that will make it comfortable.
Go through life
making everything
you do interesting to
you, and you will perform.
You will perform
very, very well.
I've always found that the
people who come into a company
and want a position or
power or money, their focus
is so much on that the
creativity part usually
doesn't come along.
The people who are
totally excited about what
they're doing, creativity
just bubbles out.
And if they're in the
right corporation, my god,
they get recognized.
They never have to
blow their horn.
The good ones never, never,
ever have to blow their horn.
Now, one last thing.
Bethany, if you're not
here, you won't [INAUDIBLE]..
A little bit about creativity.
The best way to get this going.
Einstein had this theory that--
and I really believe that,
that the mind has many levels.
It's capable of
working on problems
at all these different
levels, and it
fires to the equivalent
of an output register
when you have an idea.
And that's when you get
a flash and you think,
oh boy, then you spend a
long, long time trying to--
all the tools that
you've learned,
justify that that
thing really works.
And the real question comes,
and the exciting thing
comes, how do you
get that mind going
on those different levels?
And I believe there
is a very definite way
to do that, a very definite way.
And that is,
whatever your job is,
you decide that
you're going to do it
better than it's ever been done
by anyone else or yourself.
And the minute you have
decided that that's
what you're going to
do, what happens is you
immediately-- like a sponge,
you learn what's been done.
And then you think about it
and you say, well, how can
I do it better?
And that starts the creativity
process as quickly as
when somebody drops
that puzzle in your lap
and you don't care about it.
And then you start
working, and then you
can't see anything else.
And when you see things that
don't work, for example.
You get into a car and the
windshield wiper is smearing.
OK.
Don't think, Jesus, what a
miserable design that is.
I want you to instead--
I wonder how it
could be done better.
If you try to do
something better--
it's impossible to do
anything better that you
haven't done differently, OK?
If it's not different, it's
impossible to be better.
The inverse isn't
exactly true, and you
see a lot of examples of that.
But if you do something better,
it will always be different.
And if you simply decide that.
And the other thing is that
you're going to do it better.
You will start the mind going.
And how do you know
if it's working?
How do you know if your
mind really is working?
When you start getting things
in the middle of the night,
you wake up, you get an idea,
or you're shaving or doing
something, and you get an idea.
You're driving, you get an idea.
That's when-- I am
convinced that's
when that process is working.
If you don't get any
of that, you really
haven't had the
desire to do something
that's different and better.
Everybody can do it.
That's what you've got to
get that mechanism going.
And it's not hard.
It really isn't hard.
I once asked
Wiener, when we were
walking from the faculty club
into the parking lot one day.
I said, how come you've made
such contributions in so
many different fields?
And he answered just two words.
He said, insatiable curiosity.
He always was
wondering why or how
you could do something better.
That's the key in all of this.
So focus on this kind of thing.
Don't worry about all
the things that you think
are necessary in life
and they'll come.
The money, everything else.
I never have worried
one day about anything
like that, when I didn't
have any money or when I did.
I've never even decided my
own salary in this company.
We have a firm outside
that makes surveys.
But things go well, and you
have all of those things.
None of those will bring
happiness, by the way.
You've been told that since
you were a little kid,
but I can guarantee that I have
a pretty wide circle of people
and that doesn't bring it.
What brings it is
to your satisfaction
of doing something that's
really exciting and better.
And you can all have that, and
you're all in a super position
to get it.
Well, lest I lose my job here,
I think we'd better close up.
[LAUGHTER]
In closing, I will
simply share with you
a feeling that I've had for
quite a number of years.
And that is every--
quite frankly, every
September rolls around
and I say, oh my god, why did
I commit to teaching this fall?
How am I ever going to
fit this in my schedule?
And oh, you know, it looks
like a huge load coming on.
And every December, I look
at the class and I say--
it's a funny kind
of thing by the way.
I don't know many of you at all.
But you feel that you do.
You come into the
same room regularly
and you see the same faces,
even if you just scan them.
It becomes like a big family.
And every time that
December rolls around,
I sort of feel sad that
the thing is finishing.
And it causes me-- and it has
caused me for many, many years
to say, oh I'll do
it just once more.
And that always has happened,
and it happens again now
in December.
So you're no different, and I
thank you for that experience.
All the best.
[APPLAUSE]